on this episode I talk about dress code
meditation and horrible glasses of wine
go you ask questions and I answer them
this is the askgaryvee show
everybody it's gary vay-ner-chuk and
welcome to episode 60 of the askgaryvee
show fun fact about the number 60 oh
yeah I brought it back number 60 is the
number of D'Brickashaw Ferguson who is
an offensive lineman the Jets drafted oh
I don't know about ten years ago and
that was the first time I showed up on
ESPN pointing to my head that it was a
smart pick and I was correct before I
get into the questions this week or
today speaking of this week I know it's
been a little sporadic the two-week
vacation only one last week because I've
been hustling or the CS had a bunch of
meetings that yesterday spoke in Orlando
I think we do it today we do it tomorrow
but tomorrow night I go to LA so
probably none the rest of week guys I'm
hustling I'm trying to put up the show I
see all of you bantering we want it we
want it I know you want it I'm trying
but I don't want to put episodes in the
can I like the kind of day of stuff
going on because I get that stay in the
pulse of the vaynernation so bear with
me I am running multiple organizations
Elijah asks the dress-code at Vayner is
clearly casual do you think dress
affects professionalism or performance
that's a really solid question the
answer is very deep that the answer is
no I think that dress does not impact
performance or professionalism I know
that some people disagree with me I
think those people are going to lose
period Charles asks is the askgaryvee
show your version of meditation it seems
like it helps you organize your thoughts
Charles this is a really good question I
I saw this one come through the stream
and I and I it took me a step back
because I'm like does it like you know
what I can tell you is this I think the
brilliance of the askgaryvee show when
the business historians look back at it
is so awesome anyway
when people look back when I look back
when the team looks back when you the
collective audience looks back when you
the person that's watching this video
three years from now look at this show
and realize that I was on it was we've
created this show as a foundation point
to all the other content that I'm
putting out and so the ability to use
this show that then allows India and
Steve to help me right
medium form content I mean I think all
of you have seen that over the last you
know six to eight weeks my ability to
pump out medium and garyvaynerchuk.com
animating gifts all these things are all
coming from this central seed so the
ability to put out this show which
brings a lot of value to a lot of people
it's one great jab at the highest levels
for the people that know what I'm
referring to and then it's also a
gateway drug to more content that is
content made to be gateway drugs to
awareness about me and to create
leverage it's just one big machine of
brilliance austin asks when someone
gives you a horrible glass of wine how
do you politely get rid of it austin
when somebody gives me a horrible glass
of wine I have no version that is polite
in response to such a negative action
I'm just kidding uh you know I don't
know my mom crushed it I mean we've
talked a lot about her like it's very
easy it comes very natural for me to be
polite I I really took a lot of pride in
being the anti snob in the wine world
and for me to be like this is crap you
know I'm always using the hedge
terminology of like oh thanks you know
by the way if you like this you should
really try this and that's kind of my
polite way of saying like this is crap
you should check this out you're gonna
like it a hell of a lot more and and and
by the way it doesn't offend me and I
also you know listen
there's a big part of me that loves
tasting crap wine because it gives me
context it's one of the reason I like
following so many of you on social media
so many of you are putting out such crap
content it reminds me what is good
content and I know that sounded harsh
and I know a lot of you're like whoo
right and I know it's a rule to not diss
your audience like I'm coming to you
with straight love this is another rant
and I'm gonna do this once every 20
episodes you're watching this you're
engaging you're all giving me these gaps
you're leaving comments in YouTube
you're giving me Big Ups and then I'm
watching and I've I've had a little bit
of vacation time when I worked a little
bit I've had a little bit of travel time
where I've look a little bit more I'm
getting very deeply inspired slashed
connected to let's say the core 1000 of
you that watch this show and I've been
going down the rabbit hole and I just
want to remind all of you lack of
consistency is a is a massive
vulnerability hey Gary
my name is Michael I like almonds and
reading books my question for you is
what could cause the extinction of the
real-estate agent as we know it you keep
making t-shirts and I'll keep buying
them oh and one more thing yeah I want
to keep the tick never had any
particular the the bar has been raised
for video questions vaynernation take
note the bar has been raised amazing
question thank you so much guys great
production
d-roc you love it right that was good
that was good stuff on yeah it was good
stuff um I actually don't think that
there is a lot you know I think there is
a false sentiment in the market that
technology eliminates humans I think
technology sets up the humans that
understand how to use that technology to
leverage a head against the other humans
that don't so you know what eliminates
the the real estate agents of the moment
in the future well it's their lack of
innovation and adjusting to the tools
that are at their hands and then just
becoming a dying breed my friends I'm
not making up or talking about anything
new innovation has forever the phone the
the Yellow Pages radio television the
Internet Direct Mail video game
marketing like like every time there's
been another innovation and that will
happen forever it kills off the prior
animal unless the animal is unable to
adjust and and it's not an age thing
there's tons of 60 year olds right now
that are crushing modern day marketing
the percentage is very small and it
comes out of getting fat right it comes
out of you just made enough money at
this point you're on to new and better
things and I mean that you guys hear a
lot of hustle for me but I I'm enormous
ly happy for the gal that's 63 making
240 a year and you know put in her dues
and she wants to go to the Fancy Food
Show on that Tuesday instead of calling
a hundred people and selling another
apartment or she wants to spend an extra
week
and in an Aspen timeshare like do your
thing like when I talk about hustle
please know that I'm not judging you
it's all predicated on what you want the
only people I make my hustle stuff or
other people that are talking [ __ ] that
they want [ __ ] things to happen and
they want to win and they want to buy
I'm gonna buy the Clippers when you buy
the Jets dude you work for eight hours
you ain't buying [ __ ] and so that's
where I get pissed off but if you've
decided consciously that you want to
have a great work-life balance and
things of that nature then that's great
and those are the people that get
disrupted they've lost the hunger for a
better thing I'm not looking down at
them congrat let me give you a real
freaking secret here on the askgaryvee
show episode 60 if tomorrow I read that
there was a new drug in the market FDA
approved and I could take it and it
would take em this is gonna [ __ ] with a
lot of your heads and they could take
ambition out of my body I would do it
I'm my gift is my curse you know it you
know I I love what I do but I promise
you and this is a so many of you were
about to be disappointed with me but I'm
talking truth here I would take the pill
that would get me down to 10% less
ambition and hunger because I'd have a
little bit more balance and there's a
lot of attractive things that come along
with that balance but that's not the way
it is and honestly I'm super-pumped the
way I have it so and weirdly as I said
that out loud I kind of don't want to
take the pill but you get the gist right
and so so who gets disrupted fatcats
John asks you give with zero expectation
of return so you're never disappointed
that's really tough how do you do it
John I do it because that was the talent
that I was gifted with it is it is the
essential backbone of my success I mean
I've said it to about other things so
it's always a mix right like it's hard
to say this but like boy boy am i
thankful that boy am i thankful that I
have it I you know I look forward in
others it is a huge competitive
advantage it's it's like being born
beautiful right it's a competitive
advantage luckily for me I got both
uh for me it is really really really
really really something that I I'm so
thankful for how do I do it the same way
everybody does everything it was just
there I didn't cultivate my lack of
expectation there's no like lack of
expectation exercises that you know that
you can get into but boy is it been a
look the truth is people like people
right and people do business with people
and people sense people through a camera
through an audio podcast they sense
people I have enormous selfishness on
the things that I want to achieve but
the fact that I have this lack of
expectation and I'm willing to give and
give chances and give opportunities and
just flat-out give without ever thinking
what am I gonna get in return
knowing that eight out of ten times I
will get something out of turn and it's
pure it's just the purest version of it
I won and so like you know I have no
clue how to instill that but I can do
this why I answered this question I can
tell you that it's if it's in you triple
down on it don't suppress it
don't let the cynics outside of you tell
you know you're being too nice you're
not getting anything in return it is
enormous human leverage and I highly
highly highly recommend it for today's
question today I want to make a
statement of the day and then I want you
to leave a comment around it I did
something on Twitter a couple months ago
and I remember on New Year's Eve I
reminded myself of it and it made me
feel really really good and and I could
be confusing it because I I do tend to
confuse once in a while I don't think we
did on the askgaryvee show but we
might've but there's a growing audience
and if I've done it one they'll react to
me like you did it and like cool I don't
care and two great more people will do
it I am desperate for everybody who's
watching this episode whether you're
watching it right now or two years from
now to pick up the phone and call
somebody that they have not talked to in
over one full year and bonus points for
somebody that you haven't talked to in
over five years I want you to leave the
comment of who you called and what
happened in the outcome of it you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them
oh crap wait subscribe I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social so subscribe